we love to feel close to our pets we
snuggle them
we let them lick our faces
i think the question is being asked why
not share a meal
maybe a fancy feast so new york post
just reported that purina released their
fancy
feast petite cat food and fancy feast
cookbook for humans so you can dine with
your feline
and recipes include salmon cappuletti
and a cream and spinach sauce oh you
have me with cream and spinach
which can be paired with a cat flavored
uh salmon entree
for your kitty in the spinach and cream
gravy
um and um
immediately well i just want to be very
clear so they're teaching you that you
can
cook meals that sort of pair nicely with
what your cat will be eating right mimic
pear yeah which i think you know okay i
kind of would pair a dinner with my
doggies kibble really
yeah i you know here's i actually do
this when the eggs are like
just about out you know if i have
leftover eggs yeah i'll scramble my dog
some eggs in the morning
absolutely with my omelette so i guess i
was judging them but
i do this already so go for it i'm not
going to be
catty lots of pet owners like do some
chicken
rice eggs for their pets and a lot of
people's pets are their families
so listen my favorite phrase live and
let
live man you want to make a cat adjacent
a dinner adjacent to your cat and sit
there and talk about the similarities
you do you and you know you could do
breakfast lunch dinner even a late night
snack
you know we all love a late night snack
but real simple says dermatologist
warren
drew it could be bad for you more
specifically
bad for your skin eating before bed
weakens an enzyme that protects skin
from uv damage
drew's so bummed right now experts say
give yourself
two hours to digest before you go to bed
all right
so and go with organic food like fruits
and leafy veggies and
whole wheat bread who wants that i was
just gonna say late at night
if at 11 o'clock you're the person that
says you know what sounds good right now
kale i don't want to know i don't
they say that you should avoid things
like chocolates
uh fried foods which is all i ever want
here's here's a true story though you
know i'm on this health journey and i'm
a snacker it's my go-to
yeah but i i want to give you this
little tip okay every night i used to do
like a snack of like
you know um can of pringles or something
right i know
so i want salty things so every night i
do the same
snack i take a pickle and i slice it up
and i take some parmesan cheese which is
like the lowest of the
calorie cheeses and there's no calories
really in pickles and i have my salty
snack every night and tr
drew i walked across the street to the
store and bought you some parmesan and
pickles before the show today
just so i could show you so this is a
way you can still have that salty snack
at the end of the night but not feel
guilty
by the way this is so good all right you
keep snacking and
i'll keep talking uh you know i'm
getting married right
and um i just started planning the
wedding
uh who knows how to plan a wedding i
don't some people start planning though
really really early brides reports more
people
are considering booking a wedding venue
even before they're engaged
because of 2020 many wedding venues
weddings have been canceled postponed
rescheduled or rescheduled again
the venues are filling up but experts
say
you should probably wait until you're
like engaged to tackle that
logistical mountain and make sure you
guys are on the same page together
i have one thing to say to that
no no no no no and by the way i will say
one thing
i'm not an expert please don't do this
uh-huh i think
let's just call it's a little crazy it's
right it's a little crazy
uh you should don't skip that whole part
of getting engaged before you book
the venue how about that it's it's um i
i think it's a very risky thing to do
cuckoo
[Music]